- Well, B.J. Novak was recently at a bar
and a fan sent him Kelly
Kapoor's favorite drink.
- Yes.
- That drink is a seven and seven
with eight maraschino
cherries, sugar on the rim,
blended if you can.
(Kelly and Mindy laugh)
Have you ever had
one of these drinks?
- Okay,
so I have never had one.
- [Kelly] (laughs) Okay.
- And this is from an
episode of the office.
So Kelly Kapoor likes the
most sugary drink of all time.
- [Kelly] Which I am into.
It's a good thing her name is Kelly,
we'd get along.
- So it's like seven and seven,
it's like 7-Up.
- Yeah.
- I don't know
what the other seven is.
- It's like Seagram's 7.
Is that what it is?
- Yeah, Seagram's 7.
Seven and seven with
seven maraschino cherries.
It's, like, disgusting.
- Okay, well...
- But B.J. got sent it
and I've never had it, but I've always,
it sounds disgusting,
but I love a sweet drink.
- Here's the thing,
if it's disgusting, we're gonna find out
because I made them. (laughs)
(audience cheering)
- Yes.
- So here we go.
- Oh my god, thank you, wait.
- Thank you, Justin.
Oh wait, I love blended if you can.
- Oh my god, here, cheers.
- It is blended.
- Fully blended.
- Wait, the sugar on the rim,
that's a different pink.
- It's pink.
I'm gonna get some.
- Oh my god.
- Okay.
- Mm, mm, just giving me diabetes.
(audience laughing)
- Oh my god, it's like
straight up like a snow cone.
- This tastes delicious.
- It's like a snow cone.
- This is like something you would get,
first of all,
this feels like a child
would like to drink this,
which is bad I think, so.
- My daughter
is gonna see this and be like,
"Why didn't you bring it home?"
- [Mindy] Why didn't you bring it home?
- Yeah, yeah.
- This is like something
that they would have at
Universal City Walk. (laughs)
- And I would definitely get it
and say it's for my kids,
but really drink it myself.
What? No one does that.
- Yeah, this is awesome.
(Kelly laughs)
Thank you, Kelly,
for my awesome seven and seven.
- Your first drink that's yours.